das sei jetzt was die
russisch ukrainischen verhandlungen
sagen sie ist
gibt es
keine
lösungen die verhandlungen sollen
weitergehen
zum letzten mal haben die sei es in
istanbul sich getroffen und die
ukrainische seite hat ihrer
vorstellungen aufs papier gebracht
ja und im laufe der verhandlungen sollen
diese vereinbarungen erreicht werden
wir
brauchen vor schritt auf dem bereich der
neutralität der ukraine und
angebracht wäre neutraler
blockfreien status der ukraine das ist
eine dringende notwendigkeit
und das bekommt natürlich die situation
im donbass und auf der krim diese fragen
sollen auch geklärt werden im laufe der
verhandlungen
dank dafür dass sie diese
pressekonferenz
veranstalten sie hatten ja ausführlich
gespräche mit ihren indischen partner
vielleicht könnten sie noch mal eingehen
auf einige details
und gibt es mögliche
verzögerungen was die lieferung von
russischen waffen wie zum beispiel s400
geben konnte sie muss
ja was die verwendung von rubel und
rupien anbelangt in unseren
handelsbeziehungen so darf ich darauf
hinweisen dass wir schon vor vielen
jahren in unseren beziehungen zu indien
und china und anderen nennen uns
geblendet haben von dollar und euro und
hin zu nationalen währungen und dieser
trend wird sich fortsetzen wird sich
intensivieren
das ist natürlich und wir sind bereite
indien alle waren zu liefern die indien
kaufen will das hatte ich ja auch
angesprochen
wir haben sehr gute beziehungen zwischen
den handelsminister und den
finanzministern und
für mich steht außer zweifel dass
wir die
künstlichen hindernisse umgehen können
die durch die sanktionen geschaffen
wurde
das gilt auch für die militärische
technische zusammenarbeit
für uns steht außer zweifel dass wir da
eine lösung finden können und die
zuständigen minister arbeiten daran
die vereinigten staaten machen druck auf
in den aus
einfluss hat es auf die bilateralen
beziehungen
unsere partnerschaft er hängt nicht von
den konjunktur überlegungen ab
und das lässt sich nicht von dem diktat
oder auspressen beeinflussen
ja unsere politik hier sinnlos
und wenn dieser politik durch doch durch
geld motiviert und angeboten so ist das
ein beleg dafür dass jeweilige staaten
keine ahnung hatten von den ländern mit
denen sie zu tun haben
wie betrachten sie die amerikanische
position bei diesem krieg
leider ist der ton der frage sehr
schlecht
so dass die frage nicht zu verstehen ist
herr putin und sie sind mit sanktionen
belegt durch die usa wie sehen sie das
ja ich denke alle russen sind mit
sanktionen belegt durch die usa und die
eu als insofern überrascht
mich das nicht also damit zeigt sich das
wahre gesicht
und ich habe keinerlei zweifel daran
dass die meisten länder auf der welt
verstehen was ich dazu zu und das ist
einfach
unzulässig ist wie sich unsere sehr sehr
unzuverlässig und partner verhalten was
die indische position zu den
entwicklungen in der ukraine an lang
sprachen sie von einem krieg das stimmt
nicht es ist eine spezialoperation
die mit maximaler sorgfalt durchgeführt
wird um die zivilen
infrastrukturen nicht zu zerstören ziel
sind die militärischen infrastrukturen
und das ziel ist es das regime in kiew
seiner kapazität zu brauchen weiterhin
eine bedrohung russlands darzustellen
und diese fähigkeit ist über jahre
hinweg aufgebaut worden und gestärkt
durch die usa und andere nato staaten
die aus unserem nachbarland ein anti
russland land machen wollten aus unserem
bruder land ich habe ja das thema rubel
und rupien schon angesprochen dieser
prozess läuft ja schon seit vielen
jahren
deshalb wechseln wir auf nationale wären
über das liegt an der unzuverlässigen
art und weise unserer westlichen partner
wir wollen nicht von einem system
abhängen dass man jederzeit
schließen kann davon weil wir nicht
abhängig werden von einem sich system
und dessen meister ihr geld über nacht
stehlen können
ja was die öllieferungen anbelangt und
lieferungen von hochtechnologie so
sprach ich ja schon davon wenn indien
von uns was kaufen will dann sind wir
bereit darüber zu reden und eine
gegenseitig akzeptable form der
zusammenarbeit zu finden
im wissen
natürlich natürlich
wenn man
ganz offen ist für
alle arten der zusammenarbeit sind
besondere ja schön zusammenarbeit
[Musik]
manchmal
trifft man sie nur normale
reaktionen von
seinen opponenten und deshalb spielen
die wirtschaftlichen zuverlässigen
partner immer größere rolle
ihnen rauchen von langen jahren
stehen wir und die einführung und der
westlichen nationen und in dieser zeit
haben wir schon nützliche erfahrungen
gesammelt und
erlauben uns unser leben weiterzuführen
und mit anderen staaten
zusammenzuarbeiten
[Musik]
dass die staaten des westens von einem
plan b sprechen
gegenüber russland und dass sie nicht
bereit sind bestimmte bedingungen
akzeptieren wie
sehen sie in den in die erhaltung
indien
insgesamt
ist die gas lieferung nach europa
anbelangt so war mein präsident sehr
klar er hat angekündigt dass er ein
erlass unterzeichnet hat dass ein system
vor sie zu sehen konnte dass auch für
die westlichen länder akzeptabel dass
wir können die alte regelung nicht
akzeptieren die zahlen in ihrer währung
und dann sperren sie unseren content es
ist wie an gold fieber der goldrausch in
den usa als das land
gegründet wurde durch den diejenigen die
aus europa geflohen sind weil sie
besucht wurden also das system was jetzt
eingeführt wurde ist ein anderes system
und damit können wir die zahlung
letztlich in rubel bekommen und das war
ja auch das ursprüngliche ziel es war
dennoch ihre zweite frage ich konnte sie
nicht verstehen
nicht gebaut ist
die frage ist leider ohne mikrofon
ja ich kann sonst mir gar nicht
vorstellen dass ihnen eine derartige
position bezieht wir respektieren
dass indien sich auf seine grundlegende
prinzipien konzentriert die indische
außenpolitik fußt auf legitimen
nationalen
interessen dieses landes und seiner
bevölkerung
und mehr kann ich dazu gar nicht sagen
als sein gegner auf ihre frage
wird das viel gesprochen die
verhandlungen zwischen moskau und kiew
brauchen einen
mittler
haben sie wären die verhandlungen auch
dieses thema angesprochen also ehrlich
gesagt solche gespräche habe ich nie
gehört ich kann nur sagen die haltung
ihnen
die
frei von auspressen condic tat ist
für dieser politik haben wir
und wir gehörten eigentlich zu den
ländern
gegen die einsatz von auspressen
begriff ist
wenn indien dazu ihren beitrag
leisten möchte
die prinzipien der gerechtigkeit
durchzusetzen und unseren gemeinsamen
partnern erklären was wurde
erpressung hat keine
zukunft und keine resultate da würden
wir nur dankbar sein
eigentlich geht es um die durchsetzung
der
unteilbarkeit
die ja grundsätzlich der sicherheit und
der westen hat
dieser grundsätze grundsätzlich
signalisierte
und hat die neonazis unterstützt und
feindliches regime in der ukraine
aufgebaut
die
indische republik der gerechtigkeit und
rationale grundsätze bezüglich der
internationalen politik durchsetzen die
hat ja dann werden wir ja nur dafür sein
[Musik]
wir
hören immer mehr
nachrichten aus der ukraine über das
leiden der zivilbevölkerung studierte
für bevölkerung und
was können wir dazu sagen eigentlich
also die im lager ist tatsächlich dem
mittelalter
gleich und die reform
macht sich breit und
auch in westlichen in den letzten jahren
haben die westlichen ländern auch
also die anständigkeit nur simuliert
aber in den letzten zeit hat die
russische vw ohne hirten ausmaß
angenommen alles was aus russland kommt
wird angefeindet und
wir müssen alle solche fälle ganz
akribisch
registrieren
und alle möglichkeiten ausnutzen die wir
in unserem staate vorlegen inklusive
generalstaatsanwaltschaft
diese fälle vorzugehen und eine stiftung
für die unterstützung der
russischen landsleute im ausland zu
gründen damit die rechtliche hilfe für
unser land leisten zu können die
aktuelle anlage bedürfe natürlich
globale handlungen auf der ebene der
internationalen organisation und ich
eigentlich die unzulässigkeit
solche ja wie soll ich das meinen
handlungen
das heißt vollkommene
diskriminierung und durchsetzung der
westlichen quasi werden so durchzusetzen
also
alles was der westen geprägt gepredigt
hat freya wird freier markt und
eigentumsrechte sind eigentlich von dem
westen aktuell mit den füßen gedreht und
das thema ist heiß das gespräch ist
angereist
wir müssen die veranstalter von solchen
verfolgungen von solcher politik aus der
sicht des internationalen rechtes
betrachten und auf behandeln und dieser
schritt dieser diesem gespräch können
wir in der zukunft nicht ausweichen das
ist ein signal für uns alle das
ja dass alle mühen europas irgendwelche
selbstständigkeit zu erreichen alle
diese mühlen sind gescheitert
europäischer länder entscheiden
gar nichts europa hat sich damit
abgefunden das ist hart verbündete der
usa
ist und blind im
wasserstraße der amerikanischen politik
sich bewegt und
die usa bemühen sich die
polare welt wieder herzustellen
und hier sehen wir dass die sympathien
die er sich unter dem
schutz der americas soll sich vereinigt
haben sehen sie wirklich zu den
autokratien verkommen würde ja das haben
wir zum beispiel in ihrer im irak in
syrien und libyen gesehen
tausende kilometer von mir ein pferd und
wenn irgendwo imaginäre
drohungen wir haben ja kein stehen
da sehen sich die vereinigten staaten
vollkommen im guten recht so handeln wie
es ihnen gefällt
das haben wir natürlich in syrien
gesehen mehrmals und das betrifft nicht
nur
und
eigentlich wird dass die handlungen des
westens international
agieren
das finde das sehen wir an den
militärischen biologischen programmen
der westlichen länder die eigentlich
ganz dicht an die russischen grenzen
abgewickelt werden oder umgesetzt ja
dann ist es kein wunder dass wir unsere
interessen in schutz nehmen ja und
also unsere handlungen in der ukraine
hat das ist nicht neu nicht nur
bemühungen über neutralität der ukraine
das ist eine frage der
gestaltung der welt und
die werte und um die
gesetze der welt gestalten
und wie gesagt
wir können diesem gespräch nicht mehr
ausweichen die notwendigkeit ist bewusst
unseren partner in china indien und
anderen ländern
übrigens kurs gestern
wurde es auch ich es gesagt und betont
dass die aufgekommenen fragen ist so
schießt also das wesen der weltordnung
das muss
diskutiert werden die welt soll
multipolar gestaltet werden
[Musik]
weshalb indien das ist meine erste frage
gegen russland sind viele sanktionen
verhängt worden auch was swift
anbelangt wie gehen sie damit um jetzt
muss ich aber erst mal fragen deshalb
haben sie die frage gestellt weshalb
indien wieso
weshalb besuchen sie in den jetzt ja gut
wir sind freunde und besucher
untereinander regelt was war ihre zweite
frage habe ich nicht verstanden ging es
um swift
ja ich habe ja schon gesagt als die
unzuverlässigen westlichen partner mit
ihrem sohn begann da haben wir schon vor
einigen jahren
ein system zum austausch von
finanzinformationen
eingerichtet
in den hat ein ähnliches system das ok
und es ist völlig klar dass
immer mehr transaktionen
über diese systeme unter verwendung von
nationalen währungen folgten damit der
euro der dollar und anderen währungen um
werden die völlig unzuverlässig erwiesen
haben herzlichen dank